Richard je n'ai aurait-il pu être sauvé
le chirurgien qui l'attendait l'hôpital
Dabo ça ferme qu'une prise en charge 5
minutes plus tu restes changer la donne
ses propos sont rapportés dans la lettre
écrite par la mairesse de Saint-Erme on
va se voir tout à l'heure et à la lettre
écrite envoyé hier au ministre
Christiane big big qui aussi des
invitations
alors qu'en est-il dans de la condition
de quelqu'un qui a une rupture de
l'aorte est-ce que cette condition est
nécessairement mortel dans une
organisation de santé parfaitement petit
Frédéric Jacques et chirurgien cardiaque
il manque de l'exécuter de l'association
des chirurgien cardiovasculaire et
thoracique du Québec docteur Jacques
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on veut
comprendre un peu la situation on
s'entend vous avez prévu le patient
c'est pas une question de diagnostic si
mais les deux parties qui oppose des
points de différences tu appuies sur des
faits qui sont pas encore vérifié par un
corner on les conclusions du corps
que nous avons docteur Jacques le frère
de Monsieur Geneviève nous en donner
quelques extraits encore c'est que des
douleurs dans l'après-midi à la journée
5h30 voulais consulter pour un sac avec
des pierres aux reins c'est surtout de
ce qu'est de certaine manière et il
meurt vers 5 6h le lendemain matin donc
il y avait déjà des symptômes d'une
fissure de l'aorte
en fait oui absolument ce qu' est-ce
qu'il arrive dans le contexte artistique
de 7 ans de la c'est que la Horde
sous-jacente est déjà malade donc il y a
un problème avec la paroisse de l'aorte
impôts pour les gens les téléspectateurs
l'aorte ce que c'est c'est la plus
grande star du corps donc c'est celle
qui part du cœur et amène le sang dans
tous les organes donc habituellement
c'est 7 ans
dans un certain degré et à ce moment-là
la paroi pour être plus fragile il peut
y avoir une fissure comme vous avez
mentionné cette fille sur la 6 am
importante autour de comme tel ça peut
parler pendant un certain temps à ce
moment-là
on une sonnette de porte unité pour agir
parce que souvent c'est un peu comme les
tremblements parler 6 minutes seulement
plus important par la suite donc c'est
un peu la même chose il y a une première
de la qui est moins importante par la
suite la deuxième
donc quand les gens ont ce type de
douleur
ils doivent se présenter pour qu'on
puisse intervenir
la
nuit
bleue mais déjà les premiers symptômes
et dans la journée vers 5h30 veux
consulter penser les pierres aux
urgences est fermé est-ce qu' une
urgence avec des infirmières aurait pu
boire le patient et prendre toutes les
précautions et on appelle l'ambulance
dans le prix Auris pour 15h du matin il
était priorité ce n'était pas une
priorité il y a peut-être mal écrit ou
si sa situation est-ce que
est-ce que ça aurait pu jouer en sa
faveur il faut sauver la vie
je connais pas les détails de de la
santé du patient
c'est que c'est un compte sans qui doit
être prise en charge rapidement faut
savoir ce que 75 % des passages en
maladie une maladie qui ne le savent pas
ils sont asymptomatique donc seulement
une certaine personne qui vont savoir
par des examens antérieurs et ça va voir
les titres des foires dans une
tomodensitométrie une
échographie abdominale pour un autre
raison
ils vont
dans le
ventre
parce
qu'ils ont qu'ils ne savent pas
de
l'après-midi
exactement donc là
quand on on est assez restreinte une
fois qu'on a identifié la première
douleur on sait que la deuxième voix
grave à ce moment-là pour la rupture
comme tu es la 2e douleur importante
90 % des gens qui ne serons
malheureusement pas l'hôpital
parmi les passants qu'on va opérer pour
ces conditions-là il y a une forte
proportion qui malheureusement on est
arrivé trop tard dans deux fois j'ai
très rapidement moi je vous donne un
exemple j'étais en train d'opérer une
chose cardiaque est à l'hôpital et il y
a un présent parce que se présenter à
l'heure je lance et
donc on parle en ville le pas ça se
présenter à l'hôpital universitaire où
je travaillais et on est presque sorti
de la salle d'opération par le colis
pour l'année dans l'autre sens de
l'opération le patient présente une
rupture donc une fois que les
diagnostics y poser faut faut agir vite
dans les circonstances ou un pass déjà
une rupture on peut on peut même a été
obligé d'amener le passer en salle
d'opération
avant même d'avoir pu faire un examen
paraclinique si
le patient a pas de tension il y en a il
y en a qui est plus dans le ventre et
mal au ventre ou la même un peu la même
chose en tarif des fois ça peut être
prise en charge qui est plus rapide
que fait une heure qu'il reste à
l'hôpital
encore beaucoup de route il a finalement
la question au fond c'est que les gens
région avec des urgences faire mais
seulement si son prix avec un système de
santé incapable de répondre à ce genre
d'urgence là est-ce qu'avec ce type de
pathologie là il y a des régions à
risque ce que des Québécois qui sont à
risque de ne jamais avoir les bons soins
parce qu'ils sont trop loin les
ambulances attendre trop longtemps
il y a beaucoup de 6 et de conditions
dans la dans la question que je me pose
et puis une fois de plus je connais pas
les particularités de on
est les détails au moins donc c'est ce
qui doit être prise en charge rapidement
possible de transfert possible le moins
de temps entre les agnostique et la
salle d'opération donc si on a un centre
hospitalier par exemple régional qui
équipe les infrastructures
requises pour faire l'opération bah ce
sera pour le milieu de choix pour cet
espace et un autre de toute façon donc
dans certaines circonstances si c'est le
cas notamment chose cardiaque ça sera
disponible pour tout le patient vos
devoirs et transférer dans un milieu qui
est capable de prendre en charge la
chirurgie vasculaire qui aurait pu
prendre un chat et
comme ça
on aurait pu prendre le patient en
charge il reste il faut comprendre que
90 % des gens ne se rendront même pas
aller en salle d'opération comme tel
donc c'est très mortel comme contient si
les gens ne savais pas des gens qui est
une condition article sous-jacente est
en pôle le réflexe aller consulter
rapidement au premier symptôme de survie
survie
en ville avec les réponds dans 3 minutes
puis on arrive vite à l'hôpital versus
1h d'attendre
d'attendre d'ambulance + 140 km c'est
ici
qui viennent de toutes les régions du
Québec
ça soit pris en charge très rapidement
des chances de survie
il faut attendre le corner pour savoir
si effectivement la péter le j'étais
tellement sévère quand même avec une
organisation médical parfaite il y a
survécu par c'est ça qui qui étonne
puisqu'on est pas encore fait d'enquête
écouter Madame Tussaud c'est certain que
je me mets dans la peau de la famille
puis on en a un à être cher qui on ne on
ne sait pas qui vient de conscience
évère et elle c'est certain qu'on ne
beaucoup de questions à se poser moi ne
connaissant pas
comme tel je pense que
vous avez déjà parlé certainement plus
de
connaissance de l'architecture de son
système je peux je ne me permettrai pas
de réponse sur le
sur la prise en charge rapidement
pour voir nos émission en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]